for
[Silence]
e
for
[Silence]
just a quick REM before we get
started if you have your cell phone
devices with you please turn them off
shut them down completely or put them on
your promote and make sure the volume is
turned
[Silence]
off
allahar
ASU had
Allah
ASU
muham
Ashu
[Silence]
Salah
f
[Silence]
allahar
ill
[Silence]
in
alhamdulillah alhamdulillah
[Silence]
for
alhamdulillah
[Silence]
m
subh
[Silence]
for
my dear brothers respected Elders
beloved youth mothers and sisters we
thank Allah subh tala for keeping us
alive one more day on the path of Islam
on the anding especially allowing us to
be alive one more day in the month of
Ramadan and allowing us to enter his
house and worship him in the that
pleases him
I ask Allah subh to accept from me and
accept from you the little we do in his
path a mean and I bear witness there's
no deity worthy of worship except for
Allah subh tala and Prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam is his last
and final messenger surely who Allah
subhana chooses to guide not should get
misguide you choose to misguide then
shall can guide him back to the path and
we seek refuge in Allah from darkness of
ourselves and evil of our Deeds for
Allah is all knowing and allseeing what
his creation
does
alhamdulillah and just that a week
of Ramadan has passed
and we ask Allah subhana tala that all
the effort we have put forth so far in
this in this week earlier may Allah subh
accept it as it is and does not take any
account for that doings in that week and
we ask Allah subh to Keep Us Alive and
bless us further so we can make it to
the end of Ramadan and bless us with the
mean today I decided to I thought would
beautiful to share some quranic gems
with you guys it is the month of Ramadan
it is the month of
fasting and as
such Allah subhana T has revealed this
Quran for a reason for us to be
following one of the most beautiful
suras that I find is very interesting
and very beautiful
is there is not another place Allah
subhana tala has taken that many oats to
get get to a point to discuss the human
being Allah subh starts with
the the the MU have wrote written that
this this Surah was revealed while was
in meca and there's aith mentioned
inam have you prayed and then the Hadith
continues so have you have you prayed mu
with these suras with these two
important suras so it shows the
importance of this short but yet pivotal
Surah Allah subh
says Allah's taking an oath he's taking
aam by the Sun and its broad
daylight and we as Muslims need to
understand for some times it is common
between us folks we take Oath by things
other than Allah subhana
tala we will swear by this and swear by
that I swear by my mother or I swear
about my mother's grave or my this or
that that is not allowed that is not
allowed in Islam the only thing you can
swear about is one who created you is
Allah subhana wa tala Allah can swear by
the day the night the Sun the moon and
the stars because Allah has created
those things
those things are not our creation as
such we are not owners of those things
we are ABD and that oath is with Allah
subhana tala and that's
it and there also mentioned if a person
swears by Allah then you have to believe
it leave it even though the person is
lying that's between him and Allah now
because he's taken an oath by his
creator and if he chooses to lie in that
oath then be it Allah subh says
the Sun and its brightness Allah says
swear by the sun and the broad
daylight you know and the moon as it
follows it meaning the Moon is following
the night is the moon is coming out of
the behind the
sun and the day as it en whals itself
meaning that it shows its brightness it
gets brighter brighter
brighter and the night night as it
conceals the world around
so imagine talking to a person and the
person is trying to have a conversation
with you and he says
wall listen to me and he say okay
brother please tell me he says no W I
swear to Allah again and he say okay
brother I trust you come on say it and
he says no W brother hear me out he said
brother you said wall three times come
on no no I swear Allah so he keeps
swearing by it so imagine Allah subhana
tala is trying to get to a topic in this
Surah and Allah keeps swearing by the
things that he has created there are
seven things that Allah subhana T has
taken an oath by In This Surah you don't
get to the topic of the Surah until the
seventh until the eth verse of the
Surah Allah keeps taking an an oath by
every single thing that's he
created so what Allah says and the night
when it envelops
it in the heavens and what has
created who by whom Allah is the one
who's created
it and then the Earth and who has spread
it for you of course it's Allah subhana
tala all those seven oats Allah has
taken to get to a single when
and then also takes a last oath he says
and the Soul who made it who fashioned
the
soul and who created the soul and then
Allah subhana tal gets to the
topic there's not a single other place
in the Quran Allah has taken that many
Oaths to get to the point in a
Surah finally Allah subh says in the
verse
eight
and that knowledge of the right and
wrong Allah inspired the
soul and then Allah
says and the person who is the winner
the people who will end up on the top
are the ones who have put the effort to
purify that
Soul it's mentioned
that wasam used to read the Surah his
habit used to be when he got to the
verse
he would raise his face towards the
heavens and he would
say oh Allah give my soul give my soul
the tawa the piety the righteousness the
mindfulness to follow your Commandments
who's asking the Dua the best of the
creation wasam I brought this topic up
for a reason because before Ramadan when
I discussed welcoming the Ramadan part
of it was the Ayah that Allah subh T has
mentioned the
Quran we wrote We
prescribed for you and the Nations
before you so you can re we can achieve
tawa and tawa by itself is not
achievable as we are looking at this
Surah except as wasallam has mentioned
in Dua
oh Allah help me achieve the TA help me
achieve your
mindfulness and as such every single
thing is with of Allah subhana
tala whoever Allah subhana chooses to
guide is guided and who I choose to
misguide he is
misguided as Allah as Quran says in
Surah y
talks to the prophet Sall alaihi
wasallam he
says the
mentions for us is to deliver the
message you talk to people every single
day and you tell them about the beauty
of Islam and they're impressed and they
say you know makes sense to me it's so
understanding and you tell them okay
would you would you to
consider Muslims no man I don't I
don't think so I I the
religion I'm spiritual that's it but
don't don't ask me to do anything
else because it is not our this is not
from us We cannot put that in somebody's
heart to become a Muslim that is from
Allah subhana tala going back to the
same ay I mentioned in the every time
every every mentions
it for us to deliver the message the
rest is Allah's
honor so wasallam is reading the Surah
he's sitting and reading the Surah and
he's turning his face to the heavens and
making this
Dua and yet we think tawa is somehow
something that we can achieve 100% of
our own will and that's not possible it
comes with Allah subh T's
Aid is making the
Dua oh
Allah give my soul tawa purify it
because you're the best purifiers
you are the owner of the Soul you're the
Lord and the owner of the Soul Ya Allah
there's no control over
it there's nothing I can do of my own
you own this so as such you take care of
it for
me you take care of this Soul so when we
are reading the Quran especially this
Surah in this beautiful month we must
reflect upon it we must use this Surah
as a pivotal point to use in the Quran
to use and purify
ourselves you know if I can recommend
possibly reading the Surah every single
day it does not take you more than two
minutes to finish the Surah more than
two
minutes you know there's only about 15
ay in the Surah the first seven are just
oats Allah subh
takes you as a young man I always loved
suras that had the rhyming and to it
those was one of the best suras that I
loved because it's it's Beauty to see
that that Allah subh has this beautiful
rhythm going on in the
Quran and then Allah subhana changes the
topic after he
says Allah subh
says and whoever corrupts it corrupts
his soul is doomed meaning what meaning
the goodness and the illness is in our
hands we feed our soul what it needs you
feed it good it will be good if you feed
it bad and Ill it will be ill and then
Allah subh T mentions the story of
theud they said Allah says they they
were they rejected the through because
they were just an arrogant
nation Allah said after
that and when they rose
up when rose up one of the one of the
most wretched of them so these people
Allah is describing a person within
the who asks the
prophet for a sign of Allah subh
tala so this is where they are asked to
produce a camel for him for them so they
can believe in Allah subhana tala and
the camel is produced for them and
eventually they deny the sign of the
camel as well and the Hadith mentions
that they killed the camel they tortured
it and it eventually died and Allah
subhana tala took its revenge from the
nation basically brought down his his on
the on
the you know Allah subh finished the
Surah that they had no fear of the
consequences and sometimes when we look
around ourselves
today the people who are
involved in transgressing the boundaries
of Allah subhana tala who are involved
in making they think there is not an end
coming they do not fear that there's a
Lord above them and they take everything
in their hand as if they are the owner
and the master of the world but Allah
reminds us over and over again there is
an end coming for them there's an end
coming now I understand it's not the
full of the Surah and I did not go in
detail to discuss anything further I
just wanted to use this short time to
reflect upon this Surah and remind us
that during this month when Allah subh T
is
recommending that this month is to be
used to purify ourselves and have tawa
of
allaha that we read this Surah with the
intention that oh Allah that wasallam
read the Surah and he made the Dua to
you and Ya Allah we make the same Dua to
you we're nowhere near in our status and
piety to that time to that era to that
tongues that were there but we ask you
as a common Muslim today that struggling
with these issues with ourselves that
you pufy us you provide us a relief and
you make our souls beautiful as you
would to do it so we ask Allah
subhana tala on this day of Friday that
He blesses us with enough life strength
and courage to go to the rest of Ramadan
and fast in the true manner that we need
to be fasting and then we fear Allah
subhana tala and be mindful of him at
this time as we truly need to be and we
ask Allah subhana tala to deliver his
Aid and his comfort to all of our
brothers and sisters Muslims who are
suffering around the world at this
crucial time we ask Allah subhana tala
to make us from the people who hears the
words of the Quran and hear the words of
the Hadith in their life changes
according to
them
[Silence]
ald respected Elders dear brothers and
sisters beloved youth this month is a
month that Allah subhana tala has
forgiveness around every single thing
every single act you do is for
forgiveness but we have to be mindful of
things that might interfere with our
fasting and such becomes
invalidating so I remind myself and you
to be careful of those acts in this
crucial month of Allah subhana
tala and if that does does happen where
our fast is invalidated for a reason
then Allah subh has prescribed some
prescriptions for that and wasallam has
told us what to
do the Hadith is PR long but I'll just
cut it short inshallah on the authority
of
[Silence]
this man comes
toam Abu says this man comes toam when
we're all sitting with him and he says I
doomed I'm doomed I'm doomed sayam asked
what happened to you he said I was
fasting and I made it with my with my
wife soam asked him can you free a slave
he says I can't I don't have the
capability he said okay can you fast two
months back to
back this is the kufar this is what we
call kufar to make up for what you have
missed two
months the man the man could not fast a
day you know he have to fast two months
so he says I can't do that he said okay
feed 60 people said I cannot do that
either so kept quiet and little time had
passed when a man came up with a big you
know basket of dates so wasallam asked
where is the man that had asked the
question the man stands up said I am
right here he says take these dates and
go spend it go give it to the poor and
then the man says y there's not a single
person more poorer than me in the
Medina the Hadi mentioned smiled so much
that you can see the back of his teeth
and this was the the beauty ofat he did
not get mad at the man he not get angry
with the man he was gentle and took care
of his issues so he said you take the
dates and have it for yourself your
kufar is paid for this is this is the
beauty of Islam so we have to be mindful
if you cannot fast du do medical reasons
first and foremost if the medical reason
is just being temporarily and Allah subh
and you think that Allah will give you
the to make up your fast then it's
recommended that you don't playay KU and
you make up your fast in the time after
afterwards if you can't and there is
certainty that you cannot make up your
fast even between next Ramadan or the
Ramadan then you can pay KU so every
single day that is missed you have to
feed
60 60
people women who might be pregnant and
cannot continue fasting people who have
diabetes issue cannot fast people who
have other chronic illnesses cannot fast
the kaf I still
do and there are ways to do it inshallah
if you need to talk to me about it
you can talk to me privately afterwards
and I can make some recommendations but
those are the few things that you have
to keep in mind if the fast is
missed because of an reason there has to
be a
kafar unless you can make up the
fast now in this condition the Hadith we
discussed if that condition is mad then
a 60 of fasting continuously one after
the
other so that's a
lot so don't don't sign yourself up or
something that you cannot put yourself
out of from
inshallah I want to also remind you of a
quick of alai
wasallam says when wasam was the most
generous person in doing
good and he was even more generous
when it came to month of Ramadan so when
Ramadan
came put extra effort into his Salas in
his prayers and in his
charity inshallah after Salah today
there will be a fundraising for zakat
and for the needy that we have in the
community I can guarantee you and assure
you that we make sure that we make the
money last for an entire year because I
am responsible ible on those
applications that come through the door
the need within the community is much
greater than you think it
is if you think you're struggling
imagine those folks who have been
brought here as refugees do not speak a
word of English have entire families to
feed and they don't have jobs so we have
to be mindful of those less fortunate
amongst us Allah subhana T says you give
me whatever you can
give whatever you can there is not a
limit Allah has put on it whatever you
can comfortably donate donate Allah will
increase your rewards up to 700 times of
that there is not a better business in
the world that I've seen today that you
put in a dollar you get 700 times
back so inshallah give us few of your
minutes after Salah so we can continue
with the fundraisers if you have
attended this Masid you understand that
Ramadan is the only time we ask for
those major donations and fundraising I
ask Allah subhana tala to make this time
a blessed time ask Allah subhana tala
every single person who's donated or
donated or has the interest of donate
they increase their wealth their health
and their prosperity by 700 times let me
finish with this Hadith it is mentioned
every single day two angels consent from
the sky and they ask Allah subhana tala
those who do good in his way to increase
for them and those who who hoard the
money and do not do good in the world to
increase their you know troubles further
and further so I ask Allah subh to make
us from those folks that we give every
single
[Silence]
day
for
[Silence]
please move forward fill the gap
sarbar
illu
forar
[Silence]
ill
straighten your lines for the gaps in
between may Allah mercy upon
us
allahar
ald
[Silence]
amen
m
[Silence]
for
allahar
[Silence]
alhamd
me
[Silence]
allahar
asum
brothers and sisters Salam
alayum assalam
alayum brothers please remain seated we
need a donation of your time just zakat
for your time just give us about 3
minutes and we'll try to make it it as
brief as possible as you heard from
she
Hassan zakat is one of the pillars of
Islam and it is it purifies our wealth
whatever we have for a year it it is a
mandatory zakat on that and this is the
opportunity to multiply that zakat
multiple fold because of the month of
Ramadan so there are two things coming
together tremendous opportunity so
please let's donate generously so with
that I would to request who wants
to offer the first
$10,000 brothers and sisters anybody
want to offer this is only if you take
it monthly it's less than it's about
$900 a month so $10,000 anybody wants T
we have Dr Ran pledging $10,000
T anybody
else one more time please anybody who
would to raise hand for the 10,000
that's $900 some dollars for a month for
the year so you don't have to pay all at
the same time you can do it a monthly
payments I would to pledge
that brother at least show the
enthusiasm and we'll just move on how
about
$5,000 who want to raise hand for
$5,000 again you can make payments we'll
work with you on the credit card or
anything T brother ran here
mashallah another
one brothers and
sisters T ab ab
T at least say a little louder
T another one
please one more and we'll move
on
okay how about $2,500 two brothers
raising
5,000 Dr F
Dr Dr
Imran do we have people on this
side brother Shad T brother brother
Nadim brother Nadim
T brother
aad $2,500 that's only $200 a month if
you take it over a year period and we
know we're going to continue we just
hold the you know but if there's a
surplus we just continue spreading over
the
year what's
that another one on this side here
brother
2500 okay how about
1,000 $1,000 T brother
another one on this side here
brother another
one Dr hnan
yeah another one 1,000 that's
only less than $90 a month brothers and
sisters T Dr sham Dr shamin Dr
shamin T
who okay
mallah don't don't don't trip over
that all right maybe one
more how about
500 one or five two masah 1,000 T 1,000
Dr Lucas
tall the one the back
from Sister
FAA okay give
meah
sisters Bring It On
alhamdulillah mashallah mashallah okay
how about $500 this last time I was a
little remiss I did not call for any
anything lower than 1,000 500 do IM
Hass 500
t
masah t you see a brother right there
mashallah another one here T brother
badri T masallah brother on this side
here the
glasses anybody else about
$250 Abu Omar
AB we
have
okay brother
500 anybody how about 250 just let's
call that and any 500
mallah brothers and sisters again I know
a lot of you pay quietly and do not want
to be
mentioned ahed
500 and we really appreciate whatever
you do for this community and inshallah
your rewards are tremendous and we only
promise you that we will use the money
or spend the money as wisely as possible
and control it the best possible way
[Arabic recitation]